I have some really great video for you today
from a top contender for the most delusional
Trump voter into con in the, uh, in the United
States last week during a livestream that
I did on YouTube and Twitch, we happen to
overlap with some of Donald Trump's Maga rally
in Florida and Fox new center reporter, actually
let's call him a guy with a microphone, I
think better said. They sent a guy with a
microphone to a restaurant in Boca Raton,
Florida the day after the rally and they happened
to come across a business owner of a security
company. This is all self-professed. I don't
know if any of this stuff is true. A guy who
says he owns a security company who hires
lots of veterans who says he used to be a
Democrat but is now fully backing Trump. This
guy says he is all in with Trump because he's
patriotic and he supports family values and
he's honest. This is Trump and has integrity
of character and has delivered on his promises.
I present to you today, the man that might
be the most delusional Trump voter in the
country, at least a top contender for that
position and notice as you watch this video,
how sure of himself this man seems.
Sarah, what's your name and what do you do?
My name is Ronnie Joseph and I run a security
company. We run a security company. We were
talking, you hire a bunch of vets. We appreciate
that for sure. You're now, you used to be
a Democrat, now you're a Republican. You support
the president. Why that change and why do
you support president Trump? Well, for me
it's a, it's really quite simple. It's about
family values is about being a patriotic American
and it just comes down to being honest and
truthful to who you are. That's what I put
in, you know, that's what I value. Family
values, honesty, integrity, character, and
that's everything that president Trump represents.
You can feel like he's delivered on the promises
that he's made. Absolutely. Absolutely. He
has. Facts
do not matter. Trump is patriotic and supports
family. Values is honest, has integrity of
character and has delivered on promises. Is
there anything that guy said that's true?
Is it even true that this guy used to be a
Democrat? Maybe that's the one thing the guy
said. That is true. He's with Trump on the
issue of family values. Trump who has had
not only endless affairs and seems to barely
even know some of his children, but as paid
off some of his mistresses was involved with
people whose names I can't even say because
as soon as you say certain names, you get
demonetized on YouTube, but I think you all
know who I'm talking about. Those family values,
Trump's family values have this voter gushing
over Donald Trump. He's with Trump over Trump's
honesty. Trump is the most dishonest by number
of lies of any president that we are aware
of.
He's with Trump over integrity of character.
Trump operates like a con man. Wanna me mafia
boss. There is nothing further from integrity
of character than Donald Trump. This guy is
with Trump because Trump has delivered on
his promises what he was going to fix healthcare
and get rid of Obamacare didn't happen. He
was gonna build a wall. It didn't happen.
He was gonna fix trade. That seems to have
gone the opposite direction. He was going
to improve the reputation of the U S around
the world. No, the U S isn't even included
in many important conversations happening
internationally because of Donald Trump in
the oval office. The only value that this
guy seems to share with Donald Trump is extraordinary
hypocrisy. That is the one area where they
seem to overlap. This is the Twilight zone.
This is why facts don't matter, and this is
why I've been saying for years, we can't waste
our time on these people.
Imagine that you meet someone who says, listen,
I think Trump's a scumbag liar who's embarrassing
the U S around the world, but I'm going to
be honest with you, his tax plan is good for
me personally, so I'll probably vote for him.
We can work with that. Okay. We can talk about,
you know, listen, even if it seems like Trump's
tax plan is good for you because you've got
more money in your pocket, it's actually not
good for you in that by hurting others, it
creates societal costs. Like my point is we
can have a conversation with someone who believes
that if you meet someone who says, I love
Trump, he's honest, he has integrity of character,
he has family values that I agree with. He
fulfilled his promises by, I mean that's a
conversation ender. There is no point and
it's actually so absurd, this video that I
had people tweeting me over the weekend saying,
David, this guy has to be a plant, but I actually
think a plant would be less ignorant. We can
not win by convincing these people. We have
to win despite them period and we might not.
Sadly, there may be enough tens of millions
of people like that guy who voted for Trump
in 2016 and are going to vote for him again
in 2020 that we may lose and that's why get
out the vote is so important. Let me know
what you think about this video. Leave a reply
if you're watching on YouTube. Otherwise send
me a tweet at Dee Pacman. Follow me there
as well. We'll take a quick break. So much
to talk about today. Back from Thanksgiving
and much has happened